one glance is all that's needed to enter
Jung [ __ ] subway system the cities are
first in China to set up facial
recognition gates in all of its
underground stations the government says
it's about customer convenience this is
especially handy for people who carry a
lot of heavy bags or the people who
don't have a cache or their smartphones
who ran out of battery these problems
could be solved by facial recognition
now facial recognition cameras are being
used alongside infrared temperature
scanners to help contain the spread of
corona virus in the city of Hangzhou a
man was reprimanded after facial
recognition cameras filmed him leaving
his home before completing two weeks of
self quarantine hi-tech surveillance
cameras allow authorities to access a
citizen's travel history there are more
of these in China than in any other
country in the world an estimated 350
million roughly one for every four
people so now most commuters in jeongjo
are using payment cards or mobile phone
apps on public transport
the technology is part of the
government's nationwide plan to boost
security and surveillance cameras will
be linked to phone and other personal
data making it easier for police to
identify and monitor citizens than ever
before for some the benefits are clear I
heard about facial recognition recently
as new and seems very convenient to use
but others are wary of how that
information will be used private
information is common and the problem is
very serious is something I'm afraid of
facial recognition is used to name and
shame minor offenders such as
pedestrians who ignore traffic lights
but the government says it's crucial for
catching criminals and everyone with
nothing to hide has nothing to fear the
positive aspect is because people are
now living under the spotlight they will
be more careful with their behavior but
of course there is a risk privacy is
violated and information being abused in
Shin Jang human rights groups say
Muslims from the Uighur minority are
being monitored and imprisoned using the
vast digital surveillance network one
which several US technology companies
have helped build in jeongjo people can
so far choose whether to use facial
recognition gates but soon there may be
no way out the government is not just
using facial recognition cameras they're
also encouraging other high-tech
companies in China to develop different
tools to help manage the outbreak and
one example that we've seen was an app a
mobile phone app called close contact
now if you go into this app you put in
your personal details your national ID
it will actually pull all your travel
information which train you took
potentially who you sat next to on the
train it will give you a rating of how
likely you are to have caught the corona
virus based on that so lots of different
forms of technology being used in this
fight against the corona virus and of
course it is raising concerns in China
about
personal data and also about privacy and
some critics say that the Chinese
government is taking advantage of a time
when there was a lot of fear and a lot
of panic to infringe on people's rights
thank you that bets Katrina you there
live from Beijing